hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com
so in this video i want to make an
update on tesla because we finally
reached the level i told you guys about
around one or two months ago
and i think it's very important i tell
you that we are here right now
let's get into it
[Music]
hi guys so tesla daily time frame
this is the drawings i had guys from the
last time i did a video
so i'm not exactly sure when i did it
but i guess around maybe one
one and a half months ago i remember in
the comments you know i was telling you
guys
tesla is not bullish tesla is correcting
give it time
the force wave is gonna last a bit i had
some comments telling me
no you don't know what you're talking
about tesla is going to the moon all
right
maybe but we needed to correct first
doing a flat correction because here we
had a beautiful
zigzag so here i was expecting a flat
and guys what did we have the flat
correction so
this yellow counting didn't move guys
and you can go and check my previous
video i told you that
you know probably we're gonna have the
200 p moving average coming to this area
and that is going to act as support and
i was telling you about the 530 level
520 okay so we didn't reach
that level but it's still okay we are on
the 200
period moving average so maybe we're
gonna correct a bit more do kind of
a fake out on the downside or we're just
gonna
you know complete this c wave and do the
fifth wave right now i'm not sure guys
so once again i'm doing this video on
sunday sorry if i have some delay but i
just you know don't have time to make my
videos
every day and i have a lot of
information to give you guys so i do
all my videos on the same day or twice a
week you know i try to take a day off
as well so sometimes i have some delay
but here guys it's a you know
kind of medium long term analysis so
it's fine just keep in mind
that the five right now 580 level is a
strong support
because it's 200 period moving average
on the daily time frame
so if you break it don't panic guys we
have the 5 20 level just below
that is even stronger anyways guys you
know my idiot 12 counting here is very
nice very good you know very clean each
third wave is actually extended one two
three four five so once again guys for
those who are interested
moves up developing five waves one two
three four fives
five moves down developing three waves a
b c can be flat zigzag or triangle all
right
triangles have five waves if you want to
know more about that just click on the
link in the description of this video
and you're gonna access my video the
training that i did for you guys that i
where i sum up the book of the idiot
wave theory
but it's very hard to read i read it a
couple of times so i did it for you guys
go check it out if you're interested
so here what i can tell you is that i'm
very very convinced that this force wave
is complete or gonna be complete soon
all right once again maybe the 520
area usually for sway they like to go to
the top of the third wave
so it's even the 510 area or to the
bottom of the force wave all right so
it's either here or here
so this is also an alternative scenario
that is quite bearish so we need to keep
an eye on what happens on the 510 level
if you break it but once again the 200p
moving average is very good to use here
as well you need to combine all this
information together
you can see that the macd is very
negative guys so it's not the time to
buy
that's this is what the magazine will
tell you i'm saying otherwise once again
this is not financial advice i'm just
saying that
this level is for me a strong support
and whatever we break it or not
i'm expecting this flat correction you
know let's see what is the retracement
exactly
you know usually flat corrections they
go to the 0.786
retracement level so here so this is not
technically a flat it might be a zigzag
all right that is possible so if it's a
zigzag we might go lower
so all right just keep in mind that
we're gonna have probably the end of the
fourth wave soon so if it goes lower
it's a nice opportunity as well to buy
but once again i think that the
transparent moving average is gonna
support the price here
so i would already start to buy if i
could actually yeah i'm not allowed to
to buy
for my personal account as part of my
contract but
whatever let me just give you the target
once again
same thing you know i measured the third
wave i applied to the bottom of the
force wave so i'm not sure where is
going to be the bottom guys
but we are talking you know even if the
bottom is here
we're talking about the 1700 or the 2000
area guys all right this is
where the fifth wave is going and
probably within six months
so very bullish very bullish here so
that's it for me i hope you guys enjoyed
this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to show i see you guys